old man Peyton beats Brady in the AFC
senior quarterback bowl david blatt is
fired by LeBron James I'm sorry I bet
the general manager and there's a
seventy-five percent off sale at a
closing walmart near you this is sparta
bowls a perfect score
hello
everyone this is mark about balls didn't
get them down hey sports without balls
fans friends family it's erin foley we
are back when I say we I mean Carol and
I she's under the couch on some sort of
Capri Sun with whiskey you guys
apologize for last week not doing a show
little family emergency pops Foley he's
doing better a little a little hospital
visit this is what happens when you
smoke since nineteen twelve but he's on
the mend I actually flew down to florida
because that meant my mom had to drive
and you're welcome Florida I got her off
the roads but we are back and I listen
we've got a special episode I've got my
fourth set of balls hard Michelle
they're not impressive I don't even want
I don't even want out I don't even want
to know okay ah my dear friend and
fantastic stand-up comic Johnny lacoste
oh oh I'm honored to be here uh how do
you fourth set of balls I know it's
funny when you asked me to do the show I
go Aaron it's called sports well oh I
feel I don't feel like I'm the right fit
you know you're fine i might go take it
as a compliment I you know it's a weird
i got even know what episode this is but
i'll figure it out I remember it's like
11 10 ish I think we've done more okay
where we're at episode 116 okay I was
closed nailing it closed I'm know I've
been sprinkling uh in a hundred and
sixteen episodes I've been I decided get
out whatever just a sprinkle in some
balls now I'm sure cuz I just like the
phrase sprinkle in some balls and i'll
try to think of it how I cuz you were
one of my favorite comics before we ever
met so I think I think we may have met
because I may have been stalking your
shows and maybe that's how we became but
I don't remember that sounds amazing
you're gonna make it do you remember how
i don't i don't because we've been
friends for quite a while yeah i think
maybe it was a random like bar show it
was probably a random Barcia when
probably started talking about sport
yeah but I remember though I think I
went to a couple shows of yours before
it maybe that's how we met the remember
but I just I just remember liking you
from day one on and off the stage
hence sports allow balls guests here we
are uh and then we should do it we
should do a and and then we oh my god
where am I let's back this up I'm just
gonna write edit entire opening hey at
some point we'll mention that we went to
a padres gave together supper fun well
we got to do more baseball this year um
we are in the all things common estudio
per usual a shoot shout out to all
things common eight fantastic podcasts
fantastic stand up I'm gonna say it
again regulars of the show soft cry
Phoenix which I'm obsessed with we've
got Aaron in the studio wrong go cards
go cards well the baseball ones device
yeah sure the baseball he says go karts
ever episode I'm 116 episode I think of
go cards but I'm probably about 60 ah
Jason Heyward shut up I want to say I'm
still not sold on him he's not worth the
money you've got that biscotti yeah
that's all you need good feeling good I
have to get him on my I am my peaches
yeah my Rockford paid the Ragman
operator and my camera here that car I
cry every single type of my god me too
it's the greatest movies one of my
favorite songs to sing I swear to god
he's not a karaoke when that be amazing
i'll just do it don't worry DJ I got
this acapella oh where the members of a
all-america team wick it's another best
if you went off in saying that sorry
karaoke I would I forget that's total
Mike Trapp that's like you're welcome
America and then leave the bar let me be
reminded if we ever end up in karaoke
together that that's what's gonna happen
that has to happen ever work in Mike we
got this uh do you do weddings oh yes
Erin's getting married and Johnny diner
karaoke I'm open to it I've just invited
myself to a wedding as a karaoke
performer a backup to have meatballs the
buffet men you know it's annoying in Los
Angeles when like you know suddenly el
Senor three gin and tonics and you know
how it is and you're like oh it's
karaoke night or whatever and then you
see
world's best karaoke it's so annoying
well it's always people that hoping
they're hoping someone's there yeah to
see them like I do I don't do the show
anymore but on Tuesdays to the past year
we did stand-up at this gay bar revolver
in West Hollywood and then it may be the
last four or five months it turned into
karaoke after and so you're staying
hanging out with comics and Olson you're
like oh hold on world's best voice yeah
I should turn around like every diana
ross song every killing it and you're
like what happened to drunken Careless
Whisper that's what i do on this town I
like to bring down you're here all
awkward you like it's like kick-ass
karaoke in Los Angeles well probably in
New York too but it's next level
performance-based karaoke and every good
singer has their song yeah like that's
their showcase song like I knew a girl
who she smoked and drank my old
roommates smoked and drank religiously
on weekends and went to karaoke and her
song was hit me with your best shot I
was like her song the guy knew it and
she would just crush it yeah and then
you leave in your like I still like a
good a good tone deaf that's my sweet
spot like where I'm mid-song I probably
do it once every five years mid-song
people look at you like oh god like
first of all is she serious you know to
at what it went can this end and I'm
like no I got you three enough minutes
of careless whisper [ __ ]
extended remix hahaha one more time
shoulda known better than to chico and
then everyone just takes their own life
it's amazing oh that's what karaoke
should be anyway yeah um we got a little
we got a little stuff going on in the
sports were all so much and only spud
week there's so much wacky [ __ ] so much
stuff you know let's just talk let's
just talk about sunday uh yeah Erin
Foley glorious day in sports yes it was
cuz mr. Tom Brady is got an ice pack
over his head mm-hmm contemplating the
defensive line and the Broncos I'll tell
you what I as a die-hard lifelong kansas
city chiefs fan never been said before
I I know you never it's never been said
before it's not easy it's been a bad
road for the most part ii think i booked
you on this goddamn show because i
wanted to hear this the line as a
die-hard lifelong Kansas City chase it's
been a rough as a bad decision i made as
a kid sticking with it i did fly to
houston just for the playoff game I want
to talk about that right mazing first of
all let's just go back to the beginning
what what happened okay so i grew up in
Pennsylvania yeah I am a die-hard
Phillies and Sixers fan for life I have
more Sixers gear than anyone in Los
Angeles I still say on the biggest
Sixers fan in Los Angeles besides him
Craig shoemakers right there like we
talked Sixers all the time oh really
immeuble talk Sixers at the end of the
program too because I wanted cuz they
play in huge to how the next draft is
gonna be which is a be really
interesting when I was a kid everyone
was an Eagles fan and I just something
about it I just did this is pre
batteries at Santa and snowballs
whatever want to call it yeah I just
didn't wanna be an Eagles fan and at the
time I was like eight I like the Chiefs
logo I like the colors Marty
Schottenheimer had those big glasses yes
Cristiano coy was starting just destroy
everything with his shoulder pads you
know and then they drafted Derrick
Thomas and at that point it was over for
me like I just love the way Derrick
Thomas played he'll always be one of the
best yeah I mean I he wasn't uh he
should have used more condoms in his
life he had about seven kids or
seatbelts I know he was there but he was
great with the community he is very
charitable and very philanthropists like
and so but he was just there was no
player like him and he was my favorite
player always will be and so I just
became assess the chiefs and early
nineties is a good time it was a good
time I mean granted we did make super
bowl and our last playoff victory was 22
years ago so the last 22 years have been
just one failure and frustration that
colts game I I would colts game is
ammonia there has been multiple but the
you know like you were up by like 89 uh
what was it three years oh that was just
three years ago was just a couple years
ago I literally SAT there and I kept
thinking if I was a chiefs fan and my
god oh that was a heartbreaker here's
the best part I was at a wedding that
day and I had I had to leave for the
wedding in the beginning of the third
quarter the Chiefs were still up two
touchdowns but I was like
don't feel good about this yeah I'm
sitting in the church with my phone on
and text are going off and off scores
getting closer scores getting closer I'm
like I never had so much hatred towards
a married couple in my life and I missed
the rest of the game and it wasn't just
that let's not forget Peyton Manning
marching into Kansas City with the Colts
taking us out let's not forget Jim
Harbaugh re shirtless picture at
Michigan in 1997 taking us out cuz Lynn
Elliot missed three field goals and we
lose 10 to seven I mean it's been one
yeah heartbreak after the other as a
chiefs fan and you know granted we we
stall what we could have beat the
Patriots even without Justin Houston
even without Jeremy Maclin and obviously
Jamaal Charles has been out for three
months but they just got no pressure on
brady but none whatsoever so closer they
really played such a better second half
I literally was like okay the regroup
because it could their asses handed when
the first half and I was like wait a
minute I felt like just a couple plays
here and there the Macklin losses brutal
and Jamaal Charles has been one of my
favorite running backs to watch like
that dude just awesome yep uh an eric
bet Barry forget it's like no good
moment every week love them uh but I I I
do think at least you know um I don't
you know I don't watch AFC all the time
but Chiefs are in a good spot no
absolutely i mean whether or not the
broncos win the Super Bowl which I don't
think we're gonna I think Peyton's done
yeah and the Broncos are gonna be so cap
strap they're gonna be like yeah
strapped at a point of leg it they're
all in yeah it's gonna be like Danny
Glover's toilet lethal weapons strapped
like they're gonna have to drop a lot of
contracts so within a year to they're
done yeah charges are a mess yeah
Raiders are coming up but right now you
know even if Jamal comes back at seventy
percent we still have spencer where try
can't request that's a triple headed
monster yeah we have the draft again and
we have the most part young guys besides
Derrick Johnson but other than that with
the season we had and Andy Reid maybe
he'll learn how to clock managed at some
point I don't think so I mean could we
just queue up to super bowl I mean what
the Eagles that equals Patriots Super
Bowl hmm I hate the Eagles but the
Patriots are my worst nightmare mad ties
with Dallas okay I almost feel
I like Dallas more than the page I don't
know what it's all I do oh yeah I never
thought I'd ever say that in my life I
just I you know what it is I just like
bromo so much better than Brady me too
um because I think Romo plays with this
like infectious kind of fun energy I
mean don't get me wrong Grady's arguably
the best value of course but I just I
hate I hate the Patriots and I am
Patriots fans are the worst they're just
he's just he's so unlikable and arrogant
and even Rome you know you grow up my
whole life every day was like you were
born and raised as a giants fan to hate
the cowboys and then we moved to Rhode
Island and everybody loved the Patriots
so I I and I what I didn't mind I
honestly didn't mind the Patriots pre
Belichick Brady but when that because
they were too and 14 every year they
were you know like I liked who's it the
drew with face blood so and then oh god
the whitest man alive the quarterback
before that like with it night for blood
or east um oh my god yeah yeah yeah
niacin maybe Tony Eason whoever was on
Tecmo Bowl I think was yeah whoever does
name um but I you know Grogan steve
brule Grogan there you go yeah I like
some of those teams you know just
because everyone I like every single
person no one was a giant [ __ ] in Rhode
Island you know I mean I was like this
the only New Yorker and so I didn't mind
I didn't I didn't mind the Red Sox I
didn't mind the Patriots but then it
just came into like for me double evil
empires with the sox and patriots but
anyway um I do yes so I do think and I
like the Alex Smith you know recovery
rebirth but anyway the whole point was
yeah that clock management believe in
the Eagles Patriots i think is one of
the worst things I've ever seen because
I became a raging Eagles fan because i
hated the Patriots so much so it was
already like tumultuous to root for the
eagles and now I'm rooting for was it
mcnabb right to McNabb tio the
combination I couldn't stand and I'm
like they had that game they have that
game I mean like rock management was
unbelievable look at what happened
against the Patriots yeah he literally
wasted a possession when we were only
down a touchdown because your they were
going in the huddle with three minutes
and 20 seconds
you don't have to go me know Andy Reid
is pretending like it's the middle of
the second quarter it's like dude you
have three timeouts get the damn
touchdown and then you could actually
kick it off instead of doing a onside
kick to Gronk but it isn't it weird how
these patterns like are constantly like
they constantly repeating themselves
that's the sad part and I don't get me
wrong three months ago I was ready and
we're 1 in 5 i'm like you know what
let's lose out they gave up on any read
he blew the game against denver we're
done I'm fine with an i admit i gave up
on on Andy Reid to his credit they all
came together and even tamba hali said
he's like this is the most fun I've had
playing football in my ten years he's
like I love this team and he pulled them
together and they're looking I'm they're
looking pretty good for next year I was
I was excitedly things we're just
because I lied you know I know it's sort
of a sad state of football these days
with the with the with the violence and
they can cut and all this stuff like but
but just pure sport it's my favorite
sports and so I probably watch more you
know I have just the same enjoyment
watching let's say like a Chargers
Chiefs cape like I can I can't watch any
other sport I'm not going to sit down
and watch probably a three f our
baseball game my teams aren't in it
right but playoffs of course and stuff I
will um but you know so I I just kept
thinking every week I was like you know
and then you're doing this show you're
like oh my god she's won again oh my god
the cheese well and so it was just sort
of the back of my mind and then I
realized when do point out we were
trying to figure out like the playoff
spots I was like oh my god they just won
1000 like that was crazy it's funny once
we hit five and five there's a couple of
their comics there are diehard Kansas
City fans and so every week we do like
it I'll talk to him on the phone yeah
and I remember once we hit five and five
I remember talk to my buddy echo
honestly dude like I don't want jinx it
we're going 11 and 5 i'm looking at the
schedule if any reads good at one thing
he's not he's good at not looking ahead
yeah I said honestly I know Jamal is out
I think we're going to go 11 and 5 and
I'm looking at the rest of the AFC I see
teams only getting worse and that's
exactly yeah happened yeah yeah you got
stronger and everyone kind of just blew
it and to be honest I I think Candice
there's a lot of weak divisions in the
AFC a lot of weak division AMC south
just I mean you know Texas is ok culture
okay I think they're both going to get
better next season yeah but that
division was just hbu Slyke my NFC East
was useless useless and the Chiefs match
up well with Denver that's what I was
really sad about exercise about losing
at New England yeah I think they would
have given them a hell of a game I think
they would have to let's talk about
let's let's talk about that rule no it's
let's talk about those those games on
Sunday okay Denver that Denver New
England game i was i was in Florida with
my parents and my dad how was he doing
though he's doing but he's doing a lot
better okay good if you smoke out there
just wanna let you know don't uh because
it leads to bad stuff my dad honestly is
a medical miracle the dude is 77 right
his smoked since he was 17 shut what she
tells my mom 17 but i think it's like 13
grow up like streets of Brooklyn Irish
cat-like just smoke and also he was kind
of like like a bad boy right um but also
like the sweetest agree sir he basically
was a greaser I and but he smoked for 60
years I don't know how this dude I don't
know how he's a lot like split in his
leg for like blood like blood he's just
like he just keeps going but this is
like pneumonia COPD say he's got ass now
oxygen tank like that so smokers just
put I know it looks good put it out put
rose just it's ugly being a physical
therapist in a hospital as long as I
where you guys see so many thing like
granted anyone else get hit by a car
tomorrow yeah but looking at what people
do to themselves like to get an old
sucks to begin with yeah you make it
harder on yourself yeah good luck yeah
anyway so pops was out of the hospital
so he and we all can't stand Brady I
just want to take this moment say this
is how ridiculous my family is I'm
visiting my devil hospital and we're
talking about like the football games on
Sunday uh so he was in a spot like four
or five days and at one point I was just
I don't know if he brought it up or I
brought it up because Bridget McManus
who comes on the show a lot who I
absolutely love is a huge Patriots fan
and she can't stand Giselle and she
claimed she'd rather sleep with cheese
guys you'd rather sleep with Tom Brady
she'd sleep at em Brady without a bag on
his head or she'd sleep with Giselle
with a bag over her head and I was like
that's the most insane thing ever and
it's turn
into this running joke later right now
all I do either one two yeah I mean
they're both extremely good-looking but
I would not sleep with Giselle with a
bag of her but anyway I always said
Bridget Moynahan to me is so much more
attractive than Gisele right so for some
reason we got on the subject in the
hospital my dad literally starts going
off he goes Oh Giselle is terrible
bridget moynahan is a beauty she's an
absolute beauty cut to two days later
we're watching like blue but Blue Bloods
or whatever cop show with Tom Selleck
and Bridget Moynahan they both start in
how they're absolutely horrified by
Giselle and I love bridge avoid it look
I can't believe I'm having this
conversation about I literally was like
oh god i'm having like we have the same
taste in women yeah with my dad was a
super models are there so strange to
look at because they're almost not real
you know yeah and then all that's those
horrible stupid comments she meant that
she made after they lost the Super Bowl
and she's talking her mouth off about
like whoa he can't throw the ball and
catch it you're like shut up I do
runways I know yeah why are we giving
her a new except in any way was just
this really ridiculous family moment but
anyway we're all screaming at the TV and
so the entire time Denver was playing
Denver was on by that fourth quarter
you're like how many times do you have
to give the ball back to Brady I was
like he's gonna come back the whole time
I was thoroughly convinced he was not
only going to come back they were gonna
win the coin toss he was going to go
down the field and then I had absolutely
no confidence I mean the defense was
amazing but I had no confidence in
Broncos offense in the second half they
couldn't even score a first down they
couldn't even get a first down they were
very so lucky pedestrian yeah Peyton 17
432 176 that's not a Peyton now but
speaking of which Brady 27 of 56 and a
couple of pics 2 for 15 on third down
that is the most unpatriotic yeah
playoff game I think we've seen in quite
some time he but i have to say him
getting tossed around like a little
Barbie doll was one of the great was one
of my favorite things I just think you
know it is Denver I think Denver really
watched that Chiefs Patriots game and
they were like well let's see
the Chiefs have it they didn't breathe
on Brady all game yeah any picked him
apart we gotta find a way to get at him
and they blitz the [ __ ] out of him yeah
and also it doesn't hurt that you have
von miller and DeMarcus Ware who are
like fast yeah and that you Jackson I
mean they were just another thing is to
Patriots no run game right so if you go
into that game on and you're like all
right it's totally one-dimensional it
doesn't mean you can stop them because
of Edelman Amendola and Gronk yeah but
and if you look at uh you know the only
times Brady losses you know even giant
super bowl is you get Adam you get Adam
and you get at exactly and they have the
clientele I mean so many a lot of that
stuff to was just covered sex I mean
they were covering and that's why I
think you know they have a chance I'm
skipping ahead we'll come back but they
have a chance at carolina i don't think
i'm picking carolina but I I think they
have a chance because of that defense i
think peyton has 20 that's their only
shot pain has to play better but I mean
paint at a really good first half I
think it's one of those things in second
half for your defense is so dominating
Belichick always makes those halftime
genius moves the defense was getting at
Peyton and you just sort of play not to
lose which i think is just something
most of the time you wind up losing I
did think though they gave the ball back
so much and then right before the brady
drive to go down and score it they do
it's one of those things where it's the
most frustrating thing in football
you're up by a little amount you're not
going to throw the ball everyone knows
you're not going to throw the ball so
you run it and you run it to bleed their
timeouts yeah and I kept thinking you
get fired two-minute warning two
timeouts he's going to get the ball back
with like a minute 40 and so then I
think they had this moment of like [ __ ]
it we'll just go for it so then Peyton
throws it on that third down and it was
not a good pass it actually could have
been picked off and then incomplete pass
you give him an extra time out and I was
like well that wasn't the I would just
kept screaming at the TV because I hate
the [ __ ] is one of those damned if you
do damned if it yeah woman yeah exactly
yeah I like that they sort of tried to
get that first down to seal the game
but it wasn't I I can't believe they
want I can't believe they weren't well
that game was an example of what
everyone said about the pats going in
the playoffs everyone said the Patriots
have no running game because of injuries
they become too one-dimensional and that
the Broncos took advantage of it that's
what killed me about the Chiefs Patriots
game their running game was non-existent
blitz the [ __ ] out of Grady don't drop
any one in coverage just send everyone
at him Steven Jackson it with no with
perfect block against two and a half
yards tops now yeah that's the point
they got no one on him so Denver was
smart enough to say you know what we're
gonna bring the Thunder to him yeah and
they did and and Brady got shook yeah oh
and as I'm doing it too he did you
looked in his eyes he didn't have that
like championship no look yeah like I'm
gonna drive down this field win this
game it was like he was kind of like uh
who do I I mean some of those balls out
of his hand you're just like they were
just like literally just dumped in the
ground out of like sheer they have no
deep threat either yeah if you take away
the underneath game what were they gonna
go besides Gronk the whole its but that
Gronk catch those both those Gronk is
amazing I mean that dude is a beast I
mean Tony just want him on his team noe
Gonzalez is the favorite tighter than
ever but yeah Gronk is gonna be the best
ever I have to say who I do love is
Olson fro Carolina's Howard I don't know
what it was I started watching Carolina
earlier in the season just because I
think I was just flipping around and
maybe there is just you know just I
think maybe was like you know they were
like four no and 5 and 0 then they play
the giant whatever every single time i
watch the Carolina and I'm not like a
fan of the Carolina Panthers I thought
it was like this team is so fun to watch
and so then I just kept washing more and
more and they were probably the second
team I watched the most obviously
outside of the Giants and then when I
got close towards an i was watching a
little bit the jet more of the Jets but
whatever that's a pitt will they'll get
better but that Carolina team I just
they're so fun to watch while we're
talking about tight ends can't forget
Owen Daniels yeah three touchdowns all
year 2 on sunday i think i think if
Peyton I think what they'll do is I
think they'll they'll give him like 80
cortisone shots right and I think Peyton
knows this is it and I think he'll have
more freedom
hill-hill air it out more because they
have nothing to lose don't forget that
two weeks rest for him yeah it's going
to be amazing so I do think you'll see a
better paint and a better offensive game
out of Denver I think it was like
patchwork please God let the clock run
out let her defense hold them you know
it was like really just a prayer of a
second half but but you know those those
passes that he made those those
touchdown passes were spot on they were
awesome I think Denver has enough tools
to win I just want to look at Carolina
they just look like an all-star team and
can you imagine their season let let's
not forget when their wha what's the
wide receivers name he was really good
as a rookie last year he went down with
Annie Annie and like oh yes yes yes um I
should know this he's so good when he
went they keep referring to him they're
like keep in mind are ya keep talking
and I went back check this Carol get up
when when he went down in the beginning
of the season everyone kind of wrote off
the Panthers again like well the
Panthers had a shot to be decent welcome
Benjamin Thank You Katie barrel Jesus
Christ Harold do one thing go back to
sweet not give me the thing but down a
risky public but down the Flass oh Jesus
Carol yes she came up with it she came
up with a Kelvin Benjamin but yeah
people already they wrote him off I
didn't have Panthers would be that
special and they just keep stringing
wins together and the funny thing is
about the Panthers is this is the
feeling that I get from fans they could
still they could win the superbowl
convincingly and a lot of football fans
still be like you know what I'm just not
so sure about that this season's over
they won I mean I like football fans
would still feel like that it is I don't
know I I don't know if it's cuz it's
like expansion team Oh like they're not
the like the root of the and I don't
know what it is but I still think no one
has any real interest in the Panthers
like and they should because I tell you
Cam Newton is one of the most you know
he's just obviously gotten better and
better and better like he's never really
had like a tremendous bad season but
every every season he's gotten better in
bed
and I was watching one show where it was
like to you know guru quarterbacks and
they're like the biggest change they see
is like his second and third breed at
the line like he's not just like you
know one and run or whatever but I love
his infectious energy is so it's just
fun and he's like in him he's like a
beast he's like LeBron he's like LeBron
NFL the dude is huge he can run it he
leaps I'm like please don't leap on your
head you're gonna kill Hannon uh canon
of an arm throws off his back foot and
it goes 80 yards and he's finally got
his head on straight and you know I
think a lot of it was I think it's when
he started doing stuff for the community
he got really involved with kids in the
community was like you know what I have
a responsibility yeah and I think that
centered him strake is now he is so
dynamic yeah Denver has a fast defense
yeah but I don't know if it's gonna
matter I hope it's a good game like I
want Denver's defense to play like New
England to play like that doing I don't
know if they can repeat that performance
and I want I want everyone to be
functioning on the highest level and I
want like I think it has potential
usually Super Bowls sometimes can go
bust were they but it has potential for
fantastic game but yet so and then I
started watching like I was like I
remember that you know maybe the first
couple weeks I was like I've heard of
these two dudes but I don't you know
because I don't watch Carolina bleak I'd
heard of Luke eakly yeah and Anthony
Davis then I found out Anthony Davis
ists recover from three ACL injuries
three ACL injuries kick they remind me
of like an LT in a banks like old-school
Giants linebackers and kikis only like
four years in I I think they're I don't
know III they made me a fan I have no
reason to be a carolina panthers fan but
i tell you when you watch the giants and
you're almost demoralized by the end of
the game and then you turn on Caroline
you're like it's so fun to see a team
like play well yeah like catch the ball
and look excited and they're doing all
those fun poses in the end zone and the
balls to the little kids I love it I
think I it they're all playing they're
doing selfies they're like high-fiving
they'll
they're having their time of their life
it's just refreshing and people find
that like Oh unsportsmanlike an arrogant
I'm like [ __ ] off it's interesting it's
it's fun yeah it's totally fun and going
17 and one is pretty fun at least that I
would imagine they should have beaten
the Falcons that was just like I don't
know I don't know maybe they were paid
off by the Dolphins I think I think
those linebackers I mean as much as we
talk about cam and how I just I look at
the Super Bowl for do want to talk about
the Cardinals I mean it was rough it was
rough who is that I didn't think I
honestly didn't think it for one moment
that Arizona was really gonna
legitimately win the game but I
certainly thought they'd make it a game
I mean seven they look seven turnovers I
for one was teasing my mom because she
was like at nine o'clock i want to watch
Downton Abbey now I'm a Downton Abbey
fan but I was like I'm it's the playoffs
and we're not gonna change a channel
sure by nine clock I was like turn this
garbage on I mean I look I was like this
is this is this is ridiculous Carson
Palmer like he look like a JV squad a
week after Aryan said he's the best
quarterback in football oh he said that
in public and I love Carson Palmer I
mean it's I like Carson Palmer too he's
crazy we should all be proud of what
he's done with all his injuries and you
know but I'm sorry but if when you're
down 17 nothing after the first quarter
you were not ready no you know I'm
inhabit down what 31 nothing the week
before word Seattle and they just but
Seattle to me and i know pete carroll's
got it like a lot of baggage but i love
p Karl because I love looking at the
sidelines and seeing someone positive
yeah he's smiling he's running out smack
in the guys butts like we can do and
he's down by 31 points and you know what
they came back in score 24 so you know
what I mean I love that that's for me so
fun to watch and those are the teams
that are successful it's not these teams
everyone scream and I like the Cardinals
I didn't watch the carton of at you know
throughout the season i watch maybe a
couple games but you know the only thing
I was bummed about is I love layer
everyone loved Larry Fitzgerald and you
just want him to win a championship at
some point I don't have a feeling I
don't like the state of Arizona just you
know politically I so I have no absolute
interest in cheering for the Cardinals
at ever at any point in my life
like Palmer you like you know you have
to i love david johnson yeah good
youngtown it's about time he got a
chance to shine because he was sitting
behind Chris Johnson forever Ellington
and ya know just let him play he's gonna
dominate me yeah he did they have a fun
team if I was a Cardinals fan I'd feel
like I'd feel good about that team but
uh it was a beatdown it was just it was
it was embarrassing it was Carolina
saying I don't think people know that
we're here yet yeah let's go show him
yeah and they dabbed on their asses oh
my god oh there's a blizzard matter yeah
it was it was totally embarrass brutal
so it what do you think Super Bowl I
mean I'm first I don't think it's gonna
be like last year comes on the final
play amazing interception like we've had
some great Super Bowls I I hate to say i
don't think there's gonna be that close
you know you think is gonna be at
carolina by i'm thinking like 2713 relay
maybe 2770 I just at this point maybe no
I don't want to say Peyton can still
have a game where he dominates yeah but
I think with as fast as those
linebackers are I don't see how it's
gonna be possible they're gonna get
pressure on him he can't really move and
Carolina's offense is still dynamic
enough between the running game and the
way cam they match up so well as fast as
von Miller and DeMarcus Ware our cam is
faster yeah i don't know i just i see it
being 727 17 at the best for Denver I
totally understand that I think the I
think the offensive line in the run game
so much better than New England so I
think they won't at be as dominant and
now they know what's common you know if
they decide to do blitzkrieg which I
think would be fairly smart as Payton
can't move but I do i do think it's
gonna be you know you can I could say
there and make a total argument for
Carolina blowout and then they are the
other argument is and that's why I love
like you can you can literally talk this
about 47 hours a day until the Super
Bowl and at the end of the day you go
and they will and everybody will but
what's so funny to me is you can
literally talk yourself in and out of
every argument because no one knows what
the [ __ ]
ready but it's why I think I'm excited
you know I them I'm not gonna lie the
why I'm so excited is because see the
picture it's play yes and whoever wins
i'll be happy with if carolina wins
they've been the best team all year and
they certainly deserve to win right if
peyton and den denver wins I'll probably
never chair for Denver again I only
chair from because I am a big Peyton fan
and it would be sweet to go out on top
and and you know so I'm gonna thoroughly
enjoy the super bowl and uh and it's
ghetto so it's it's a win-win I I digest
at the end of the day I just don't see
anybody being Carolina I just don't you
mentioned if Carolina does blitzkrieg
honestly I'm so confident that diva I
don't think they have to do blitzkrieg I
think they could sit back and just cover
everyone oh I'm sorry when I meant I
meant Denver doing blitzkrieg oh they
can they're gonna have to but it's not
yeah man i don't know i don't know the
thing is then you've got this cam you
can do blitzkrieg cuz brady doesn't move
but cam can go everywhere cams at that
LeBron level right now like you said any
yeah certain certain players they get to
that unstoppable level that no one can
figure out and I think he's right now I
think he's there because the offensive
line is super salad for Carolina cam is
extra special amazing and also Stewart
Jonathan Stewart has been having the
season of his life right and then you've
got Olson you've got Ted Ginn jr.
playing out of his skull like Ted Ginn
jr. but what if you're like I'm sorry I
remember him to 80 years ago at Ohio
State I don't even remember anything
he's done his pro career you remember
when he got drafted by the dolphins and
everyone booed all the elephant's be
drafted him like ninth overall and I
remember at the little press conference
the GM amidst all the booze of dolphins
hit this is excusing us just wait until
you see this guy return and kickoffs and
punts he's the ninth pick you [ __ ] you
don't draft someone at nine for special
teams and that was his reason for
drafted it was so funny he's super
athletic you guys oh god he's got some
loose hamstrings it's like Al Davis he's
real fast I mean well you could sneeze
on Ted Ginn he's gonna get hurt like
yeah that pic was insane that pic was a
second third round pick uh but yeah i'm
i'm i'm super fired up I it's going to
be a it's nice to go into a super
all and I know I'm taking it too
seriously but it's nice to go into a
Super Bowl where you like both teams and
you feel good about whoever wins that's
it's a rarity usually I'm just like I
can't stand that effing team you know
what i mean and i still have not i'm not
gonna say i haven't recovered from that
butler interception i still have not i
will never get over that i will i will
never get over that I understand that is
going to be talked about until the I I
will never forget where I was and I was
had to be almost contained oh it's like
me and those Len Elliot field goals yeah
yes the same look you just those herbal
and I'm not even like a crazy Seattle
fan and I was losing my mind and since
then Marshawn Lynch has refused to run
yes that's a good point he's like I'm
going to take a week off and be on this
stationary bike could look out there and
all right so potential will do just a
couple more football stories and move on
but I uh yeah I mean ok so I read a
couple things are so super bowl
predictions that's on my list your we're
both going to Carolina yep Aaron what do
you think I'm just hoping it's not like
the last time done I know I know I know
wow I mean that's yeah that's all i care
about is don't let this first snap over
the head safety I was like oh no you
don't do that that's a step up yeah yeah
yeah no yeah no I think we're 48 to 80
something like that it's just the hour I
don't want Peyton I don't it if I just
want Peyton to play well he doesn't have
to win but if he just plays well cuz
i've been super protective of him if he
just want to play as well and you know
in carolina wins great I just don't want
him to be like demoralized and
embarrassed that's the only thing I
don't want to happen but yeah I do think
I do think cuz of Denver's defense it's
not going to be a blowout but I do think
it will be a solid you know 1014 it but
honestly it's the final score was 47
seven I wouldn't be that I i'm not i'm
not gonna be surprised yep i don't think
it will because of the Denver defense in
fact i'm gonna i'm gonna say it's going
to be closer than not
I'm going I'm going 27-13 you're going
27-13 yes all right I mean it's close by
halftime and then Carolina pulls it away
I'm doing uh 3222 ooh let's break this
down how do you get 22 I don't know wait
all right and Johnny you're doing what
27-13 Aaron what are you doing I was
gonna say 30 20 carolina right all right
over unders 45 and a half right now mmm
the gamblers that's a little high
that'll change and it's also negative
negative minus three and a half for the
Panthers yeah all right so I mean yeah
all right little just be fun to look
back on my to look back on a predictions
true uh and those are set in stone they
cannot be changed ah ah I do real quick
cuz we talked about kenza uh I did read
this Oh in the cam newton jersey sales
that that to me and that to me was
surprising yes i love this story he is
currently 22nd in the NFL in jersey
sales but let me give you a couple names
that are in the top corner uh number one
love the guy he said a great career i
can only assume he has a massive family
swallowing up his jerseys that's Jason
win Jade's oh oh okay he's not the first
but you're saying on this list it's just
the fact that he's yes no no I it's
insane to me that's ridiculous and
another one who is in the top 20 but i'm
gonna guess should probably be down near
the hundreds at this point after the
season the Eagles had is demarco murray
yeah a lot of regrettable purchases
there uh hello Luke eakly being ahead of
Cam Newton that's that makes no sense
out that to me is like people really
don't like him Newton I don't know why
you wouldn't like him noon yeah yeah
he's he does the I don't know I mean
every way what's the difference between
him doing what is it called the dab yeah
verse Aaron Rodgers doing the the belt
they're so different it's nothing it's
and the fact that Colin Kaepernick is
still in the top 20 means it's just
basic that's drunk 20-something girls
wearing the Kaepernick jerseys they
think he's what he was three years ago
and Teddy Bridgewater I like that little
surprised he's top 20 do you know
honestly without the helmet you give 20
people you give 20 if you line up Teddy
Bridgewater no no no one would know who
Teddy Bridgewater was nope and how about
Jimmy Graham Seahawk jerseys it's just
because the seahawks of an insane fan
base that they do but this year he was
not Jordy Nelson didn't even play he's
back basically time kid I don't get it
I'm I'm on all aboard all aboard uh yep
i am i'm in i'm in with Cam Newton me
too uh Manziel rg3 who's going to be in
dallas will they be in dallas i read
that tight that headline I was like
that's an interest gives a [ __ ] really I
mean they're both I'm losing who would
you pick that rg3 I'm rooting I'm
rooting for rg3 I still think there's a
good heart and a somewhat decent brain
in there yeah Manziel is a piece of his
huge I can't even I was I was Pro
Manziel but I've been beaten down by
that douchebag beaten down he he is so
that's what you mentioned he's the
affluenza Brett like yeah he thinks he
goes to vegas and pretends to be
somebody god I hope that story strip if
he hasn't learned by now he's not gonna
learn he's going to be out of the league
in three years yeah he had it a couple
decent games for Cleveland but he ain't
worth a headache by the way I got an
inside scoop you know a Carol big
big-time gambler her husband she met on
a pas poker tournament in Las Vegas uh
his her husband's name small blonde and
I she got a tip from one of her friends
that did confirm that Manziel was in a
wig at a poker table so we heard it here
first I think Cleveland got what they
wanted which is a shitload of ticket
sales for two seasons now they made
their money off him and now they're
gonna try to pawn him off on someone
else but at this point what would you do
is get it what would you give up in what
I guess just like just a backup a safety
as a bet you know I mean like agency
they're lucky if they get a fifth or
sixth round pick form yeah if that are
you gonna watch the Pro Bowl [ __ ] no
when is it Sunday no no remember when we
all watch the pro bowl and it was fun
yeah I always used to enjoy the Pro Bowl
and now I'm like I have I don't even I'm
just gonna hope that nobody gets hurt
honestly I'd be okay with them getting
rid of the pro bowl and just naming a
pro bowl team yeah what's the point like
I don't want anyone getting injured yeah
I just was like oh my god the pro bowls
on sunday i literally just like randomly
caught that yeah um here's a fantastic
story uh and this is a shout out and
then we're gonna let's talk about Blake
and maybe some philly shout outs in the
interest of women talking sports which
of course I'm obsessed with I forgot to
mention this because this I think
started maybe two weeks ago school Sarah
Spain jane mcmanus and Kate Fagan Kate
Fagan has been on the show hosting new
ESPN radio show uh yeah we'll see a new
radio show on ESPN it's so exciting yay
ladies 12 to three eastern time on
saturdays it debuted debuted on january
nine so we'd a couple weeks in which i
will start listening to immediately uh
you know it's men men men men men on
every single channel radio TV whatever
it is and you know every week I do my
shout out to ESPN women espnw calm
because it's the only source for viable
female sports and they are all it k
Fagan it used to be a basketball player
she's a journalist jane mcmanus covered
NFL and sarah spain is also just
absolute hysterical I and journalists
and now and they all do really fun
pieces for you spend w and now they have
their own show what is the show oh it's
called the trifecta so listen to the
trifecta 12 to three eastern eastern
standard time on Saturdays I would love
that to become a daily thing eventually
I know I hope it will too because
they're all smart and funny and fun and
great and they're all individually on
other shows yeah you know which is
really already great but I think ESPN is
in a very interesting situation right
now in the last year they've lost Bill
Simmons they've lost Keith Olbermann
they lost Colin Cowherd yeah they need
to build new stars yeah they're like a
franchise that needs to build new stars
and the three of them are
awesome yeah this is a huge movement I
think it's a brilliant move and I would
love it to become a daily thing is i'll
be honest i listen to sports radio all
day I'm on Fox Sports the shows are the
best they got dan Patrick I'm a huge
colin cowherd guy yeah I love kalanchoe
a bit of a blowhard but he doesn't bore
ya love Colin Cowie I love pet roasted
money they're all their shows are the
most intelligent funny shows on radio
for it for my money all ESPN has gone
for right now is Max and Marcellus who I
love dearly yeah besides that I can't
listen to local LA radio I just hate the
lakers oh and I don't give a [ __ ] about
the ram so I can't stand as long as the
lakers win enough games to give the
Sixers their draft pick I'm fine yeah
listen let's transition right into that
shout out to the ladies also shout out
to Katie Nolan garbage time that's on
Fox and sunday on Wednesdays she's
fantastic I did her podcast when I was
in New York I did manage fanner cool
she's super [ __ ] cool yeah and her
show is fantastic and it's Wednesdays it
used to be sundaes no it's Wednesday's
so watch that on foxsports1 because she
is a delight she said she's national
treasure um and to see any woman
passionate and smart and interesting
talking about sports is a it's a goddamn
dream sequence that's the kind of show
that is my dream show like to host
there's the way it's set up like a
Marilyn when I heard she was coming out
that was like that's the same damn thing
I want to it's so cool yeah no it's
awesome it's just fun to you know I
think well it's just fun that women are
getting more and more opportunity um and
they're not just stuck on a sideline no
you know and we've been covering it like
I cover everything every week when I
went anyone oh let's do this before we
do it because I wanted to talk about
seventy sixers and the whole interest of
just supporting other women is this
whole year the 2015 was really fantastic
you know just something moved Jessica
Mendoza full-time Sunday Night Baseball
I mean that's you never thought that
would ever happen right and then you've
got Sarah Thomas NFL referee you've got
a becky hammon on the sidelines for the
sanitary is so good she's Nancy
Lieberman up in Sacramento like it's
just you're fat you're like Jesus thank
like it's something
this is what i posted online for
feel-good moment of the week last week
yes real quick they are putting Mendoza
with Kurt showing are they animal thank
i think i think it would explode hit
he's such a misogynistic piece of [ __ ]
as a Phillies fan i hate saying this but
like a kurt your your baseball pitcher
your content we don't care about your
politics just shut up out robo calls for
george bush shut yourself anyway uh he's
whatever that i know there's people of
all different political persuasions that
watch listen to the show I'm just saying
I don't like them uh I all sort of like
him in the booth I just don't like them
and I think there's other guys that are
just I don't know John Kruk I like mud
cookies Schilling I can't stand um is it
something to do that he was a red sock
probably anyway okay moving on uh ya
know Kruk no um Schilling move to some
other show and I think Kruk moved to
some other show I think it's Mendoza and
I don't know who the other two guys I
have to fact-check that i would but
Carol's well Krug may have gone I think
mlb.com yeah I think he moved to mlb.com
day with ten would be network and
Schilling got Michelle tuesday or monday
we got moved to a desk in the basement
like an office space yeah I'm not gonna
lie I was outside of the Sanford
speckled ballpark when it was some World
Series game I didn't have tickets but I
was my ex's in san francisco and i was
right by the stand because i was like at
least let's walk by the stadium and just
like kind of feel the energy this is
maybe three years ago and in a like golf
cart going to I guess report post game
was whatever those three guys it was
schilling and the other two that that
are always in the booth maybe it was
crock she'll in someone else and she I
made eye contact with Schilling and I
gave him the biggest stink eye on the
planet do you think he noticed now but I
noticed and I felt proud of myself go
give him the stink eye where to go yeah
it's but it's very mature and you threw
a socket him and then I was like take a
bloody sock i'll give you seventy-five
cents and i'll set it on fire a good
financial choices chillin okay so ladies
Buffalo Bills higher NFL's first time
female assistant coach and the football
world just got a little sexist that was
the the headline of the new york
magazine story unless sexist little less
sexist yeah but it is a more sexy
I got a little sexist football got a
little more sexy right ladies yeah uh
yeah Buffalo Bills hire new coach on the
new news higher and coaching staff
catherine smith gay catherine smith
first full-time female assistant coach
in NFL history I'm super super pumped
and how about the guy that dead hired
her of all people of all people mr. Rex
Ryan Catherine leave your shoes on
seriously we don't want to see what Rex
does if he sees your feet he's he's a
great yes and I didn't even know that I
knew the other Ryan was his brother but
I know they were twins I didn't know
that he yeah and he hired him as
defensive coordinator that's probably
why Rob decided to look like Dog the
Bounty Hunter they didn't want to look
exactly a lot of luck tough luck yeah uh
but yeah the twins are coaching and they
hired a lady so now I'm a bills fan I
guess in a way we work in a
quality-control special teams and not
sure where the quality control means I
don't know what it means but I'm just
happy she's there yeah what do you think
that means I don't know good that
couldn't even just said special teams
yeah quality control our job is to find
our next Steve Tasker okay I know you're
gonna do got you know yeah it's kind of
it it's kind of interesting I don't
exactly know what it is but I'm just I
just puts little stickers inside the
jersey all right stop it who brought
Aaron that's not that's very funny
though uh yeah i'm i'm thrilled i'm
thrilled so shout out to my ladies at
ESPN W and catherine smith who i tried
to follow on twitter but i couldn't find
her i'm looking forward to she might not
be who knows and I'm looking forward to
listening to the trifecta that's gonna
be really cool yeah I'm a big Kate Fagan
Finn all of them really but Kate's great
yeah I met Melissa Raonic we had on the
show in the beginning uh maybe I'd say
the first 30 40 episodes she's a
fantastic ESPN writer and I met her
through a friend and she was like maybe
this is like a year ago she's like oh
I'm buddies with Kate Fagan and I knew
Kate Fagan from ESPN debu and she lives
in Brooklyn and I was literally doing
some podcasts out of my friends house in
Brooklyn yeah and she came over to like
my friend's apartment and and she had
the book she had her book coming out and
it was really fun it was great so hope
to reconnect with her
I will say this to this but there's been
a in my opinion a big increase in really
good females on the sidelines laughs
like 10 years ago it was just like oh
you're pretty here's a mic how's the
worst and and there's still a couple
like don't even get me started on
actually made a video on when the whole
Brit McHenry thing came out some I do
Jeremy Schaap impressions so I didn't
know what yeah i did a fake interview
with briggs cuz I just she's the step
stereotypical I don't care how nice she
pretends to be I don't care how the
video was edited you don't say that
should anybody I mean she's a nightmare
but there are some really good ones like
I think I have you seen name's Kayla her
tongue sorry but that's the one in the
in the checkout line of the parking
thing yeah the party but there's a
really really good one that I like her
name is Kaylee hartung she does a lot of
the college stuff okay but she's really
good Simon reported like she will not
just ask the fluffer questions she
really will ask like knowledge of like
she knows her stuff and if she doesn't
get the answer she wants she will step
back in front of the coach like nah man
you're not going yet answer my question
that's awesome and she's not to mention
drop-dead gorgeous but she does her job
and she's good at it so yeah phil simms
drop-dead gorgeous what a what a jerk ah
I love my boys I love my by film ah
alright so let's talk about um we have a
couple minutes left here I do because
every time I see you I always think um
76 I'm sorry it's bad and I think we had
a conversation maybe two years ago maybe
even when we went to see the Padres
which let's definitely do again that
ballpark assault and we should go Oh in
errands errands Padres him okay no I am
NOT a part oh no no your cards fan but
you're from san diego I totally
apologize parking baseball I i'm down to
see a Lakers game too yes we have to see
a Lakers game boat just I just have to
see that I just I'm gonna see him play
before they work yeah i mean i've seen
employees hurt right I mean we gotta
give a shout-out to Elena our girl Elena
oh yeah yeah what's due well let's do
that that's in the basketball uh hub
okay uh all right start seventy sixers
and we'll do a shout out to Elena Delle
Donne who's my favorite I do and yeah
okay the whole the whole point is I
think every time I see you I just I
remember having a detailed conversation
with you probably on the ride back from
San Diego about the state of a fair
is the seventy sixers and i think i
think it was like you know maybe even
two years ago now and we were saying you
were saying you know draft picks to it
but then it felt like it got I thought
it was supposed to get better last year
and it didn't know you're giving me like
a five-year plan that's exactly what the
GM Sam hinkie said when they hired if he
goes give me five years and when we had
that conversation he had just gotten
hired oh ok so he cleaned house and
granted a lot of 6 or fans have jumped
off the ship they don't understand
what's going on I'm still completely on
board because if you're not LA or New
York you have to build a team from
within because you're not going to
attract a ton of free agents yeah and
they've made a couple questionable moves
you know I think trading drew holiday
was a good idea cuz the long run I love
drew but he's going to have too many
injuries they're already piling up on
him and Nerlens Noel as a young kid he's
getting better drafting JoEllen bead got
a lot of criticism but if you look at
last year's draft it was awful and they
were at number three he was the best
option at the time if you look at the
rest of that first round there weren't a
ton of people they made a mistake with
Evan Turner years ago DeMarcus Cousins
is a beast what are you gonna do yeah
that happen to six points oh my god he
had over a hundred over the two games
yeah he's just he's unbelievable
unbelievable wait say passed on to me
pass the test on cousins the year of
Evan Turner DeMarcus went fifth and it's
Sixers took Evan Turner at number two
well in all fairness Evan Turner was on
fire for you played Ohio State right he
was but the reason they didn't take
cousins was because they're a lot of
questions about his personality which
was a weirdo which still has folded yeah
you know yeah and the beast at the same
time the Kings aren't good so numbers
are numbers but yeah um and there was
another there's a couple questionable
moves they made but overall like like oh
people are mad about the Michael
carter-williams trade because he's
playing well for the Bucks but there's a
writ Brett Brown I trust he said that
he's a Popovich guy he's a disciple from
his tree if he says Michael
carter-williams is not our point guard
of the future I'm gonna trust him and
they trade him and in my opinion I think
we have our point guard it's guy named
ish Smith he's a journeyman he's played
for six or seven teams they had him last
year they let him go to New Orleans they
got him back two months ago for two
second-round picks
and they've won seven games now with him
like last night for example 20 points 9
assists five boards one turnover with
nobody to pass the ball to yeah it is
legit and I think he's a legitimate
starting NBA point guard and they got
him off the scrapheap and so right now
it just like is this the third season of
winning like a handful of games but they
weren't the worst team in the league the
last two years everyone wants to crap on
the Sixers there's been worse teams the
previous two years but the Sixers are so
obvious about the rebuilding process
everyone wants to jump on them the NBA
got mad mba got furious that's why Jerry
Colangelo got brought in because the NBA
the teams were coming to the league
saying look when we play the Sixers
we're not selling tickets yeah which I
get it so they brought in Colangelo has
some damage control he's kind of
monitoring Sam hinkie that kind of deal
wait till for people that don't know
these names just explain who they are
Sam hinkie is the GM of the Sixers
former GM of the Rockets he's very
Moneyball style yeah and Jerry Colangelo
is a legendary basketball operations
general yeah a guy so he's kind of
coming in as a consultant but I'm still
on board I think we have Darko sarrak
coming over from Europe next year he's
definitely coming over yeah so who do
you have who do you have right now well
we've got the jahlil okafor yeah who's
arguably uh down the guns in stop
swinging I'll be fine he'll be they they
brought in Elton Brand as a as a little
grandpa form yes great but he's got
better post moves than almost anyone in
the league at 20 years old he's so fun
to watch yeah I don't even like Duke but
I loved him well I love watching him
play gotta get better defense which I
Yankee will bet he's like 12 yeah actly
Nerlens Noel 21 years old he's all she's
he's raw yes yeah he's raw but he's
getting better yeah we have ish Smith we
have a guy named Robert Covington who I
think on a good team is the second or
third guy off the bench who could just
hit threes yeah other than that God you
really got rid of you got rid of a whole
bunch there's not much on that team we
we told you know you and so coming up in
the draft do you just like you're just
going to keep trying to draft these one
or two picks this draft is going to be
very interesting the Sixers are on pace
to have four first-round picks possibly
five because we have our pick yeah six
years have the Lakers first-round pick
but its top three
that's why we're praying for the Lakers
to start winning some games if they
finish with the fourth worst record or
better Sixers get that pic when they
finish one of the three worst records
right under the second worst record they
keep it so deep down the lakers
organization wants to lose they won't
admit it but they don't want to finish
with a bad record and not have a pic
right that's gonna make them look stupid
who did they give up for that pic it's
all stemming from the by nimble oh ok
all right so that's like years in the
making yeah and the Sixers also had the
Miami Heat first-round pick the Oklahoma
City Thunder first-round pick and they
made a deal with Sacramento they made
Vlade Divac look really stupid they
traded for Nik Stauskas who was a first
rounder last year he's not ready
gameplay but they also not only did they
get him for nothing they traded some
euro stash players they made a deal with
with Vlade Divac to wear this year next
year the Sixers can choose to swap
first-round picks Wow just now it's not
going to happen this year as the Sixers
are way worse yeah but you never know
what'll happen next year yeah all right
so you're still confident in the in the
seventy Sixers moving forward absolutely
not to mention our cap space is so full
we can sign to max deals if we want to
possibly close to three mmm Kevin Durant
sorry that made me laugh that was
mean-spirited I just gonna be doin good
no he's not gonna he loves all of us and
I don't know why nobody stays but
another rumors the Knicks which I would
be a dream if I'd array on my Knicks yet
we have the unicorn we've got Durant and
mellow oh I action and how good
porzingis is so exciting as one of my
all-time favorite things in sports is
the NBA Draft me too when not not just
the draft because I'm like man but when
they get a foreign player and they're
like the next pick you know for whatever
team there let's say the new york knicks
hop up on opposing i never goes home a
[ __ ] yeah i was a drink I favorite
every single like you know Brooke like
God the [ __ ] is this guy like just
screaming out and this guy is so good
it's redic well the Sixers almost took
it the rumor was we were going to take
him at three and then the Nick
had the fourth pic yeah I was like look
we already got him bead and Lord knows
if he's ever going to play I don't want
this european guy that weighs 112 pounds
yeah any 7 feet tall and granted we got
Okafor so I'm happy Nik sir happy so I
worked out but dude poor thing I don't
you saw that play last night Westbrook
goes in for Westbrook goes in for a
layup and porzingis takes his hand out
not only blacks it just takes it yeah
just took it off Westbrook's and and
started the fats break out like that any
so well spoken an adorable he's putting
muscle on to which a lot of he's got to
start drinking the unsure around the
clock ya gotta keep that calcium uh yeah
so it will be interesting but this
choice i wanted to ask you about the
seventy Sixers this upcoming NBA Draft
is going to be it's not going to be the
best talent wise yeah but it's going to
be very exciting to see where the moving
pieces happen because it's a one player
draft everyone wants Ben Simmons yeah so
whoever wins that draft lottery more so
than most years it knows who they're
taking I have yet to see him play I've
just heard you know every time you log
on to anything its Ben Simmons Ben
Simmons but Trish's Trisha's uncle is
assistant coach at LSU he said he used
to coach with Chuck Daly in Detroit and
now he's coaching Ben Simmons day yeah
well not for long not maybe one and done
that's why with these first-round draft
picks you know they're one and done so
it's gonna take years anyway for them
just even get any basketball in them
yeah he's so legit though I mean it I'm
I just need to make a point of just
watching him play praying for the first
pick um he's a game changer he is a game
changer well I mean so I've heard Elena
Delle Donne one of my favorite all-time
well she's a couple years into the
league WNBA player chicago sky i would
go out of my way to watch university of
delaware games to watch her play yes in
the world you know she I don't you know
her backstory but she got recruited for
UConn and then bailed and it was just
she said it just and she played
volleyball for two years at Delaware and
then started playing basketball wait it
was just pressure being away from home
number 1 teen can you omit I mean you
kind of its getting stupid we need
someone else to beat UConn and I'm a UK
I'm confused she got she got she went to
uconn on a scale
Elena Delle darted there yep never
played for bail for basketball because
she was like number one or two in high
school coming out from Delaware okay
bales goes to university delaware now
she can't play because that first year
because of the you know transfer
transfer role plays volleyball just like
becomes probably an all-american at
volleyball for a couple years then then
starts playing basketball she just she
said it was her whole life she was under
so much pressure she wasn't having fun
and she just and then takes delaware
just basically on her shoulders into you
know i think they made it to the sweet
16 police or senior year and it was
ashamed to because I watch a lot of
Delaware games and I sat down my dad and
I was like because we go crazy for March
Madness I was like you have to watch
this woman play because they've watched
so much women's basketball because I
played and then they don't watch a lot
of women's basketball in March Madness
I'm like you got to start watching more
and dad was like all in I mean you watch
her play once and she's mad mesmerizing
it's just that like she just had almost
you know passed to herself what she I
team around everybody say yeah except i
would look like the Washington I was
like oh god these Delaware kids are
legitimately fairly good basketball
players but I just kept saying oh my god
she's gonna be so psyched to graduate
and get into a WNBA team where she
doesn't have to do everything yeah you
know it was like LeBron in high school
you ever watch those highlights no it's
LeBron and four dudes going wow it's so
funny um I just saw this on Instagram
and of course I just love it because she
I just as a joke sent it to Johnny
because she she had posted her latest
project where she's like building her
own doggy bed it's all these like
carpentry tools out I was like oh maybe
she's gay I say the finished product yes
it's beautiful yeah it was just it's
just a little shout-out to my girl Elena
Delle Donne maybe maybe or you've got
your carpentry skills lead you right
into a gay bar and I might be waiting
maybe that or if you're not I'm 60 what
she's 65 oh yeah I don't know how to
make you 65 she's taller so Harold is
really fun to watch and she seems like
she's a great like awesome personnel
yeah and just like a super cool family
good ambassador for the game yes time
for some itunes
shoutouts go on itunes and leave sports
without balls on itunes a five star
review and i will read them on air how
fun is that we haven't done that in a
couple weeks because i've completely
dropped the ball but i'm picking up um
Mia curtsy maybe that's your real name
that's a fun name December 11th leaving
us review first discovered this podcast
while listening to garbage time it's a
must listen for female sports fans love
this pots podcast yay yeah yeah Mia slap
Maxwell that's the greatest name ever
Aaron is the best thing show is amazing
I feel honored to have participated in
any way shape or form I'm not sure what
and I hope Carol gets her act together I
don't know who slap Maxwell is but you
probably have emailed me stuff so thank
you and futi foodie for life overall I
really enjoyed this podcast it
definitely approaches sports in a unique
way and there isn't any other podcast
out there like it that's fun Erin is
consistently hilarious and guests have
been great thank you for life slapback
swell mia curtsy that's awesome go on
iTunes leave us a review and I'll read
it and can I just say this if you have a
chance to see Erin do the art of
stand-up comedy you need to thank you
I'm seriously I'm like I said I was a
huge fan before we became buddies and
now like you're one of my favorite
friendships because I learned by well I
learned so much by watching you do
stand-up and then like we [ __ ] about
life and sports and it's like a perfect
thing it's the greatest thank you for
saying that that's so sweet I'm blushing
ah fail good moment of the week yay life
is hard there's a bunch of [ __ ]
everywhere so we have a feel-good moment
of the week I love the story Florida
basketball cop brings Shaquille O'Neal
as backup in game with local kids this
dude let me just tell you real quick
this guy police officer gainesville
florida which i can imagine as a tough
place to police white cop hears a noise
complaint goes on route to a noise
complaint in a impoverished neighborhood
in gainesville finds a bunch of kids
playing basketball does he take out his
gun and start shooting no he does the
right thing as a normal person it starts
playing basketball with these kids has a
great time I don't know how he connected
with Shaq I think maybe even check saw
the story Shaq saw the the
video okay I guess it went online and
Shaq actually a lot of people might not
know Shaq trained to be a reserve cop a
me and in Los Angeles he's loves law
enforcement and he oh he said he wants
to be a cop someday yeah he always
wanted to say you want to be a sheriff I
remember that I will be shared I want to
be sheriff yeah so he sees oh that's
right ok the Lakers start had seen a
viral video of white shooting hoops with
the kids contacts them comes over
surprises these kids gives him a hundred
bucks each if they make these foul shots
ah and then talks to the kids after
about just like getting out of you know
he's like I lived in a poor community
you can do anything of course people
aren't built like Shaquille O'Neal uh
but inspiring like get out you know you
can do work hard get out of you know uh
you know whatever just just a just to
get out of these situations and do the
right thing and be good kids and it was
so sweet I love what he said most my
favorite thing was he goes be a leader
not a follower he said it like three
times doing that's awesome he's like
study dude in school be a leader not a
follower that's how you're gonna get a
bad I hear he's like I was here I got
out of here so can you so awesome is
pretty great and I like how shacks
putting on that dad wait he is put on
that dad way know him and chuck wagon
hanging out here work um yeah so
congrats Bobby white police officer
Bobby white you're awesome Shaquille
O'Neal you're awesome so thank you for
the feel-good moment the week and that
is our show yay and please tell us where
you're gonna be and tell us about your
blood drive okay on twitter at Jake wast
oh it's JQ you ast 0 or JLo comedy calm
but most importantly so all things
comedy actually is sponsoring a blood
drive that so Steve Simone and I many of
you may listen to Steve show good times
on all things comedy we did a blood
drive together back in September's a
two-day blood drive and it was it was
amazing and we filled every appointment
at Children's Hospital Los Angeles saved
a lot of people and really help them out
so we're doing another one Saturday
februari 13th it's a one-day blood drive
and we're basically trying to get the
entire community together because as big
as Los Angeles is the hospital's always
short of blood because we live in a city
where everyone's so consumed with
themselves and yeah they
think about it so we're trying to spread
the word around that hey give blood save
a life because you really like we've
affected so many families directly by
doing these blood drives by getting to
know them and and and bill burr was was
nice enough to mention this GoFundMe
account on his podcast and because of
the money that was raised we've directly
affected three different families that
all have kids going through cancer
treatment we've helped them out
financially and really taken them from
dire situations to like more manageable
situations all because bills and amazing
human being and he mentioned it Steve
and I are doing the best we can to
spread the word around the comedy
community and all things comedy is nice
enough to help us out with a two so it's
Saturday februari 13th all you have to
do is hit me up on social media at je
crois stowe or if you know Steve Simone
hit him up or hit you up 3 2 336 1 2 441
is the number to call that's 32 33 6 1 2
441 if you know anyone in LA or you live
near La please come out it's an amazing
day you meet amazing people where is it
it's at the Children's Hospital of Los
Angeles on Sunset Boulevard ah nice
that's fantastic banner on all things
comedy calm is click on that make an
appointment oh I have one comedy thing
if you're going if you're in Arizona
i'll be at the stand-up Scottsdale
februari fourth fifth and sixth and then
driving back in the wee hours and Super
Bowl Sunday yay hey come see me dudes
jokes or something yeah and mole will
link to the the blood drive and will
link to your website so people can not
only see you or fantastic comedian your
own right you do all these fantastic
blood drives your healer sure awesome do
my best now that's so exciting I'll be
there I love are you in town yeah I'm in
town and i'll be there please come yes
it'd be great to hang out I'm gonna
write down and everything i'll bring
some people will give the blood give the
blood Aaron k Foley calm I'm going to
put some tour dates up be in LA for a
bit then I'm going to be in san
francisco and then kirkland washington
and then I just start the realms also at
Aaron Foley comic you can tweet at me
and sports without balls show.com is
every single episode I'm behind on a
couple of them but don't panic I'll get
the rest up thank you to all things
comedy Thank You Aaron okay
nailing it Johnny thank you so much
thank you for being a fantastic set of
balls on the show you got it source
without balls fans have the best day of
your life
you